indeed we are following that breaking
news that fire you talked about there in
the arts district downtown that's right
we've actually got bianca holmen she
just arrived there on scene at
charleston and casino center joining us
now with the latest
good morning john good morning heather
so the fire has been put out there are
about five las vegas fire and rescue
trucks here on scene cleaning up from
putting out that fire it's actually
just a structure we learned that there
were no injuries
and
no one hurt
as they put out this fire so that's some
good news to report there it is right
next to an escape room right here on the
corner of charleston and third in the
arts district lots of units responded
and were able to put out that fire
pretty quickly but we have learned that
there were that it's actually an
abandoned building and you pass these
fire trucks it's actually boarded up
with some boards uh plywood on the
windows
it may be that there were could have
been squatters there could have been
people uh who were transient and um
living there in the in the building but
we're going to be learning more in just
a few moments we will keep everyone
updated online and on air as soon as we
get some more details about what could
have caused this fire early in the
morning here in the arts district we're
going to send it back to you guys in the
studio